this weekend on history bookshelf evan
thomas talks about his biography john
paul jones sailor hero father of the
american navy
the book describes revolutionary war
hero john paul jones who served in the
newly formed navy and through ambition
and ability rose quickly through the
ranks
this is an hour
i'm delighted to be here in annapolis
tonight we went to herndon day at the
naval academy and watched those poor
midshipmen scramble up the greased
monument very exciting i think it took
him less than two hours which was fast
my topic tonight is john paul jones as
you know um abigail adams at john paul
jones the great american naval hero in a
paris salon in 1784.
i dare say she wrote a friend you would
be as much disappointed in him as i was
i expected to have seen a rough stout
warlike roman
instead of that i should sooner think of
wrapping him up in cotton wool and
putting him in my pocket and sending him
out to contend with cannonballs
he is small of stature well proportioned
soft in his speech
easy in his address polite in his
manners vastly civil
mrs adams wrote with some surprise that
jones knew quote the etiquette of a
ladies toilet as perfectly as he does
the mass sails and rigging of his ship
he knows how often the ladies use the
baths what colors best suits a lady's
complexion what cosmetics are most
favorable to the skin we do not often
see she observed the warrior and the
abigail thus united
jones mastered the arts of the abigail
which is a 17th century literary
expression for ladies made
partly as a tool of seduction
he was a great ladies man and a rake
he
consorted with prostitutes and
courtesans and countesses and
chambermaids pretty much any uh woman he
could get his hands on as far as i can
tell from the record
indeed one of the jobs of the american
minister in paris during the
revolutionary war was to deal with jones
mistresses
thomas jefferson had to pass secret
messages to madame t one of his secret
mistresses who was supposedly an
illegitimate child of uh louis xv
uh jefferson finally drew the line when
one of jones's mistresses hit him up for
a loan
he refused
uh but jefferson uh much as he was
annoyed by all this
saw that john paul jones was as
jefferson put it
the officer he said i consider this
officer to be the principal hope of our
future efforts on the ocean
and if you go to monticello today you
will see that on the same shelf where
jefferson put the bus of george
washington and benjamin franklin
and the marquita lafayette is john paul
jones bust as well
john paul jones uh
joined a continental navy uh our
earliest navy
that was by most standards uh uh
pathetic
uh uh it was up against a royal navy
that at that time had 68 ships of the
line the continental navy had zero
uh it had mostly a ragtag fleet of armed
merchant men
uh and most of its captains spent most
of the revolutionary war
uh hiding in harbor avoiding uh the
royal navy the the continental navy had
very little impact on the british with
the singular and important exception
of john paul jones
there were other captains who fought
bravely but nobody fought as bravely as
jones
he was
for starters a great seaman
partly for the reasons that the ladies
liked him he was very meticulous and
fastidious any of you have sailed know
that sailing punishes sloppiness and it
rewards care uh and jones was
extraordinarily careful in fact he drove
his cruise crazy because he was finicky
and he was always fiddling with a
rigging to get it just right but it made
him a safer and and uh a safer sailor
who who never lost a ship and endured
some pretty powerful storms
he was also uh phenomenally brave uh now
uh naval officers of this era were
expected to be brave they went into
battle uh in their full dress uniforms
standing exposed on the quarter deck the
shot and shell indeed uh lord nelson
when he went into the battle of
trafalgar was wearing uh his medals
which gleamed uh his star of the nile
and supposedly the sharpshooter who
killed him was aiming at the star of the
nile when he shot him through the chest
to the chest of the battle of trafalgar
so officers were supposed to be that way
and yet there was an unwritten rule
that if your ship uh was inferior and
outgunned and outmanned after a putting
up a suitable fight you are allowed to
strike your colors if you look at the
casualty rates of single ship actions uh
during the age of sale typically in a
crew of 300 uh there will be a loss of a
dozen men maybe 20 men they were not the
carnage was not huge in these single
ship actions because by and large one
ship would strike to the other when it
was clear that they were outgunned and
outmanned
this is not true of john paul jones uh
he took in his most famous sea battle he
took his uh ship the bonham richard up
against a faster uh better better armed
heavier uh ship with a better trained
crew
and he fought for three hours in an
astonishing bloodbath
both ships lost half their men
jones famously when the british captain
uh called out to him and asked do you
surrender do you strike declared i have
not yet begun to fight
now he probably didn't say exactly those
words
they were first uttered i think 45 years
later by his first lieutenant however
he did say something defiant during that
battle contemporaneous records suggested
he definitely turned down the demand to
surrender by the british captain and he
probably said something that was closer
to i'll sink before i'll surrender
uh there's no question that he that he
was that he showed a a a an absolute
fearlessness in that engagement and and
many others he was a ferocious character
ago he was a war lover going into battle
he was giddy he was high uh he would he
would write we know this from letters
that he would write immediately after he
went into battle here's one from his
after one of his first engagements with
the british frigate aboard the slip
providence again way outmanned and
outgunned
uh he gave this frigate he taunted it
and gave it the slip
and uh
he he wrote uh
uh he wrote about his uh our hair
breaths our hair breath escape and the
saucy manner of making it must have
mortified him the british captain not a
little uh he gloated over his victories
uh
the next time he took on a british
frigate on a wild goose chase
uh he kept it going
for eight hours and and he wrote it till
night with her sable curtain put an end
to this famous exploit of english knight
errantry he thought of himself as a as a
knight errant
uh uh so he was giddy and high and yet
in the very next letter he would sulk
and he would pout uh he would be low
he would blame everybody for his
problems uh he had very high highs and
very low lows uh in a more therapeutic
age today where we uh uh
all read too much uh
too many freud knockoffs uh we would say
he was bipolar or manic depressive uh in
those days uh he was just considered to
be
outrageously brave and outrageously
moody
uh
he was a very complex character and
others saw that in 1780 after dining
with jones john adams wrote this is the
most ambitious and intriguing officer in
the american navy jones has art and
secrecy and aspires very high
eccentricities and irregularities are to
be expected from him they are in his
character they are visible in his eyes
his voice is soft and still and small
his eye has a keenness and wildness and
softness in it
now when adams wrote intrigue he meant
in the sense of plotting adams was sure
that jones was plotting with benjamin
franklin against him i won't surprise
you to know the politicians were just as
paranoid in
1779 as they are today and they and it's
interesting to me reading about the
fights between the founding fathers many
of whom distrusted each other and
thought that they were out to get each
other and that was especially true of
john adams who was a very great man and
we owe him a great deal but he was also
pretty paranoid about his political
enemies
uh and it's certainly true that jones
was phenomenally ambitious uh you would
say i would say i do say it's his
defining characteristic uh he
many signs of this he loved medals and
awards uh he wanted to be made an
admiral never was but i was glad when
louis xvi made him a chevalier so which
is the equivalent of a knighthood
he had three coats of arms made for
himself in his during his lifetime each
one would get a little bit more
elaborate more curlicues and symbols and
ever
he refused to wear the uniform of the of
the continental navy with a red vest
because he thought it was too dowdy he
preferred the uniform of the british
navy which had a white wasket uh because
he thought it was more dashing and it
was typical of a sort of singularness uh
john adams described jones as quote
leprous with vanity
uh it was all true and and jones knew it
and admitted it in his correspondence he
wrote my desire for fame is infinite
uh and indeed it was but it was a trait
that he shared with the founding fathers
he was not unusual in his ambition and
uh these these the founding fathers were
the original self-made men uh very
ambitious and a good thing they were too
because that gave them the essential
rocket fuel if you will the the drive
and the desire uh and the vision uh that
helped set us free a couple of centuries
ago
uh they these men were came with
equipped who came equipped to change the
world they literally wish to change the
world
and they they came of age
at an interesting time i really got into
this reading about i i i was educating
myself about this period and it was
clear to me that this was a you could
feel the sort of tectonic plate shifting
here if you were born
in mid 18th century you were born into
what they called the great chain of
being
which meant that you had your place and
it was fixed
uh lords were lords and peasants were
peasants and there was not a whole lot
of social movement
you knew your place and you had to keep
it but that was beginning to change the
enlightenment had come this whole idea
that you could improve yourself that you
could change yourself that you could
make yourself and better yourself this
was a a
a new uh concept not for all people's or
all classes it was mostly restricted to
people who are educated but it was
starting to take hold in certain certain
groups this notion that human nature is
not immutable and that you can change
yourself very important to jones uh this
idea that you could be perfected by a
liberal education it's no coincidence
that almost all the founding fathers
were first generation college graduates
they had they'd found out how important
education was this was two of jones
jones was self-educated but uh with an
education that ended at the age of 13 he
taught himself to read shakespeare and
poetry he quotes pope and shakespeare
and in his letters uh he frequently
quotes uh uh uh addison's cato
uh he quotes uh uh
a poet uh
named thompson who who's best known now
for writing rule britannia but at the
time was a sort of a primo romantic poet
who wrote a volume called the seasons
that was a jones favorite uh
and jones interestingly befriended
in boston a poet tess
who was the first great african-american
poet uh phyllis wheatley who had been a
slave
freed by her uh owner a a rich bostonian
because she was so brilliant began
writing poetry i don't know quite how
she developed the skills to have had the
education to do it but she did and and
uh
jones and she had some kind of a
flirtation or relationship not quite
clear but they knew each other and they
said each other poems
uh so he had a he had literary ambitions
he had he had he wished to be a
gentleman but he was definitely not born
a gentleman and this is important to his
story he was the son of a gardener
uh living on the south uh shore of
scotland on the firth of solway
very beautiful gardens uh my wife also
who's here and i walk those gardens uh
quite unchanged in a couple of hundred
years this is the age of the great
landscape gardeners capability brown and
the beginning of that whole flourishing
and jones father was
an artist a true artist uh who created
this splendid magnificent thing but was
treated like a servant because he was a
servant he was a gardener and and jones
lived in not a squalid hut but a pretty
small
white wash shack it's still there today
uh a stucco white washed house a couple
of rooms in which they stuffed in a
pretty big family and it's in a
beautiful place but it's pretty rude and
mean
and uh he grew up without
any hope for advancement
so he did what many
young men did in that age he went to see
he went to see at the age of 13. he
wanted to join the british navy to be a
young gentleman but he lacked a social
connection so he had to settle for a
merchantman he was an apprentice on on a
merchant ship
and what an awful life
that must have been uh think about
living in wet wool for months on end
uh
uh just the physical labor there's one
small statistic i saw in one of my
resource books
from 1808 to 1815 the royal navy handed
out
an amazing 29
712 trusses for hernia
there were only 80 000 men in the
british navy at any one time and they
handed out almost 30 000 trusses
that gives you some sense of the
physical labor involved in being a
seaman on one of these ships now we know
that jones wanted to get off of that
lower deck on its physical labor and the
way he did it was by teaching himself or
getting a master to help him learn to
navigate
navigation was the difference between
the officer class and the semen in fact
the officers didn't want you to learn
how to navigate because if you could
navigate you could mutiny because if
because you knew how to get the ship
from here to there so they wanted uh uh
their their semen not to learn how to
navigate jones being a quick young fella
uh uh learned how in his octant which is
like a section that is over in the naval
academy uh museum i think it's his
original octant and that was the key
that was like a key that turned a lever
that allowed him to enter the officer
class now he had to go very slowly he
was a second mate on a slaver which was
a
something i don't think that we can
fathom the grotesqueness i mean for the
slaves wretched beyond belief they were
stacked literally stacked like cordwood
but but even for the officers a debasing
dehumanizing experience other ships
would did not want to sail downwind of a
slaver in that age because the century
was so great uh jones quit it uh because
he was so appalled by it uh but had
trouble getting a job but worked his way
up and by the time he was 21 years old
uh was the master of a merchantman
starting to make a little bit of money
and uh
unfortunately he killed a man and jones
had a temper
he was never beloved by his crews
and uh he refused to pay one of his
crews because he wanted to reinvest the
money in cargo and sell it in england
and uh his crew mutiny and the the
ringleader a big burly fella came after
him this is according to jones with a uh
some kind of a spike or a a
a a heavy object and uh jones ran
through the sword and jones telling the
man impaled himself on jones sword
uh we only have jones account we do know
however that he didn't want to stand
trial he he fled the island uh the next
day so he didn't couldn't even stand
having his own officers testify in the
trial so i wonder what the facts really
were and he came to america to start all
over in fact his name wasn't john paul
jones his name was john paul he was born
john paul the jones he added on uh
because he needed a new name and a new
beginning in the new world
uh he came to fredericksburg virginia
he thought he was going to get some
money because his partners on this
merchant ship owed him some money and so
he wanted to settle him set himself up
as a gentleman he always wanted to be a
gentleman this is a burning desire all
through his life
uh but he was scottish and in that age
in that time in in colonial virginia in
the commonwealth of virginia uh
the
english squire arc he looked down on the
scots in fact one of the lees
lamented that uh virginia was becoming a
macocracy as he put it
so jones ran into some prejudice just
because of his ethnic roots which he
disliked in fact he was he fell in love
with a girl named dorothy dandridge
and uh was rejected by her because he
wasn't good enough for her family uh as
a scotsman with of uncertain background
uh and so there he was rejected in love
uh no money unable to become a gentleman
uh uh uh
he needed as uh
he needed as a a fellow founding father
put it alexander alexander hamilton
wrote in one of the first letters we
have from him i wish there was a war
because wars are a good way to get ahead
uh uh and and
fortunately for jones although he was
not deeply political the revolutionary
war was breaking out it was 1775.
jones went to philadelphia and became
got a commission one of the very first
commission signed in the continental
navy as a lieutenant and indeed was the
first one to raise the it wasn't the
stars and stripes in those days it was
called the grand union uh but the
american flag of the new colonies over a
warship a converted merchantman the
alfred in uh in philadelphia and the
river there in the schoolkill river in
december 1775
and so jones had his his war his ticket
uh to to success
and he fought well in early battles uh
the continental navy didn't fight
terribly well but jones did and started
to make a
started to make a name for himself but
he never felt that he got the
recognition that he truly deserved he
was always his letters are full of
complaints about how why am i 18th on
the seniority list when i'm much better
than that and the answer was that
politics were the same then as now and
and the
seniority list was heavily affected by
who you know and whose brother you were
and whose cousin you were and jones uh
began with no patrons he had some
masonic connections jones was a mason
interestingly which was a real key to
social mobility in that era and that
helped jones a little bit but he felt
that his true uh
qualities were being slighted and he was
not wrong about that
he he moved himself up finally and his
real breakthrough came because he was a
strategic visionary i don't want to make
too much of this but he had an insight
that the others did not and that was
there was no way that this little
continental navy was ever going to
scratch
uh the royal navy uh by trying to take
them on ship the ship they didn't have
the firepower for that the only way to
really be effective in terms of naval
strategy against the british
was by what today we would call
asymmetric warfare
or more bluntly terrorism
jones understood that you had to scare
the hell out of the british people
and the way you did that was by
attacking their homeland by raiding
their homeland burning their towns
taking their taking
kidnapping people now it's i don't want
to make him out to be osama bin laden
and knee bridges he was not he did not
he did not target civilians it's
significant that he did not target
civilians to kill them but he sure
wished to scare them and to
inconvenience them and so in april 1778
in his new
ship the ranger uh he set off
to
raid the british coast his specific plan
was to uh
burn a fishing fleet and the port of
whitehaven which is a little port up on
the north west coast of of england uh
and then to kidnap and earl
uh he got to whitehaven but before he
got there and this happened to him again
and again his crew mutinied uh he found
out that they wanted to throw him
overboard his crew wanted to make money
they wanted to they wanted to be
essentially privateers men they want to
capture merchant ships divvy up the
cargo make some money jones was not in
it so much for the money although he
liked money he was in it for the glory
he wanted to to to win himself some
military honors and so he heard that the
crew was going to
throw him overboard when the sailing
master was the ringleader came up to him
jones put a pistol to his head that was
the end of that uh and although i don't
think jones got a lot of sleep on this
cruise
they went into whitehaven and jones and
a few men bravely spiked the guns in the
fort uh meanwhile the rest of the men
went into the pub and got drunk
uh one of them who was a traitor ran out
and alerted the town folks and jones uh
they managed to light only one ship on
fire jones found himself standing on
this pier facing about ten thousand
angry people of whitehaven armed with a
pistol and a cutlass uh he did get away
his crew almost left him behind but he
did get off and right away that morning
they headed right across the firth of
solveway for
saint mary's island where he was
planning on kidnapping the earl of
selkirk who was a social friend
of uh the lord of the matter where he
had grown up it was a little payback
time here a little social revenge
uh and jones was going to kidnap the
earl of selkirk uh unfortunately the
earl was gone he was uh in england
taking the baths
and uh jones uh had to resort to
stealing the earl silver
which he did
uh and this is a source i have to say in
joseph to jones's credit this is a
source of some embarrassment to him
he wrote this long letter almost
hilarious letter to lady selkirk
protesting how he was a gentleman of
fine feelings and fine sensibility and
only because of the exigencies of
warfare do you have to do these
desperate things and and that could be
in future time could he possibly be of
any service to her ladyship and going on
and on and on
her husband wrote back saying uh now if
you're such a man of fine feelings how
come you stole my silver and tried to
kidnap me
to jones's credit he returned the silver
he bought it back from his crew it took
several years but he did return the
silver supposedly with the tea leaves
still in the teapot he took out a letter
in the newspaper to announce that he had
done this gentlemanly thing but but he
did do it he wanted to see himself
as as a gentleman
his mission was laughable in one way in
terms of its ineffectualness but in
another way it was stunningly successful
if you read the british papers from the
time
it was a a triumph of psychological
warfare the british papers are full of
the pirate paul jones and how could they
do this and where's the who's the why
can't the first lord of the admiralty
stop this and where's the british navy
because the british people believe they
were protected by what they call their
wall of wood the royal navy they had not
been invaded after all in what 700 years
a british tan had been burned up and
burned i think for a hundred years since
the dutch had done it uh and the british
had come to expect rather the way
americans did before 9 11 that they were
safe and that they would always be
protected and that this would never
happen to them this happened on the
continent maybe but it didn't happen to
the english and now it had happened and
it raised the cost of suppressing the
revolution they debated it in parliament
i mean you can feel the tensions rising
and so as a psychological act it was it
was uh it was very uh it was successful
and very very clever
and yet jones did not get much credit
from this not from his own folks not
from the uh american commissioners in
paris partly because jones was such a
pain in the neck he was always bugging
them for
more ships and more money and more honor
and and ben franklin and john adams got
tired of it uh jones famously wrote this
letter at this time uh that he wanted a
fast ship for i intend to sail in harm's
way a a phrase that has endured and
certainly in the last couple of months
you hear in harm's way all the time
he wrote this famous letter but he
sailed into his most famous battle in an
old slow tub no fast ship for jones he
was given a converted uh indian men uh
an armed indian men uh it was so slow it
could barely keep up with the flotilla
he sailed with
but he did uh after attempting feudally
attempting some more raids uh he wanted
to he wanted to essentially kidnap the
city of leith which is the port city of
edinburgh and was blown away by a storm
and foiled he finally encountered
a british man of war
uh and a sloop and jones initially had
the advantage he had with him
four other ships french ships
and uh versus the two british ships
jones raised the signal form line of
battle and the four french ships all
went in the opposite direction
now i'm tempted to say that some things
never change but that would be wrong
so jones had to take on the serapis uh
uh a far superior ship
uh with his old
slow leaky tub the british captain
sailed circles around him uh two of guns
jump big guns uh 18 pounders blew up on
the second broadside he was very quickly
outmanned and outgunned and he did the
one desperate thing that he could do
he
grappled with the british ship and
essentially created a death grip uh
jones himself lashed the bow spread
they had a complicated circling and and
the british ship uh bowsprit came over
his stern and jones lashed it to the
mizen himself
uh and the two ships ground together
uh jones used grappling hooks they were
bound in this death grip
uh and there they were for three hours
pounding away at each other the
cannonballs after a while went through
jones ship and out the other end uh it
was absolutely bored full of holes
at the end of those three hours
both ships caught fire jones's ship was
sinking to the to the people on the
bluff there at flamborough head they
would see under a beautiful moonlit sky
this is a harvest moon in september
1779. uh they saw this these two ships
locked together this kind of sulfurous
cloud there was no wind the sulfurous
cloud of smoke rising straight up it
must have seemed hellish to look down on
it it certainly was hellish to be in it
and the victory was finally won
when jones uh was initially defiant one
of his gunnery mate tried to strike the
strike the american flag jones knocked
him out by throwing a pistol at his head
uh manned his nine pounder and started
cutting away using this nine pounder to
cut away the main mast on the british
ship basically sawing it down with
cannonballs
uh a as an enlisted men meanwhile
climbed out over
on a yard that hung over the british
desk with a bag of grenades and began
dropping them down and one of them
bounced down through a companion way
down down the steps to the british gun
deck
exploded and there was powder on the
deck there the powder boys have been
sloppy after about three hours i can
understand why and it created a flash
fire it burned a lot of british sailor
and now the british captain felt that he
had done his duty
and and threw in the towel and and
surrendered he was very haughty with uh
jones uh jones let him have his sword
back and the and a little bit later and
the captain refused to take it from this
pirate uh jones later heard that the
british captain his name was pearson
richard pearson had been giving a
knighthood for having fought so nobly
he'd become sir richard and when jones
heard that hearn that was now sir
richard he said i should fight him again
and make him a lord
uh
now jones was finally got the hero
worshiped he wanted from this battle
this came at a good time in the
revolution we hadn't had a victory in a
long time a french fleet had intended to
invade uh england and had been ravaged
by an epidemic of disease it was a low
point both in the french struggle
against the british and in the in the
american revolutionary war they wanted a
victory they needed a victory and this
gave them a victory and jones was fed in
paris he had lots of lady friends he
went around
cuckolding
various gentlemen
and at one point they tried to lower a
wreath on his head with this wooden
contraption in the french opera and for
once he had the forbearance not to
protest that that was going too far so
he didn't he didn't do that but he
certainly loved the attention yeah he
was made chevalier he was inducted into
the fancy masonic lodge there he had a
great time uh but he finally had to go
home
his trip home was one of the great sea
stories of all time because he got
caught in a storm
uh on a ship that was so vicious in the
bay of biscay that he ended up having to
cut away all his mass to survive i mean
talk about radical surgery to survive it
was not unheard of the in earlier storms
uh british ships had done this uh when
in doubt when when all else is you
sacrifice whatever you can before you
start sacrificing your own crew and and
he created turned his ship into a hulk
and eventually to stay off the rocks
there uh and
and threw out sea anchors which finally
held after he had cleared away all his
mass
uh and then jury rigged a a small sail
to get back to port uh there were men
literally on their knees praying on
their deck thinking that they were going
to die and jones sue seamanship was able
to save them
he finally came home to philadelphia
where he was not given quite the glory
that he wished for he wanted to be made
an admiral but he had so antagonized his
fellow captains that they started
spreading rumors about his untoward
personal life around in the continental
congress so he never got his uh never
got his flag uh they did give him a ship
of the line the first ever built the
america but america was so the
continental congress was so broke that
when the french lost the ship of the
line congress just gave the america to
the french leaving jones without a ship
and that's how he ended
the revolutionary war he was not done he
was still a young man in his 30s uh and
he wanted some action
he went to france
wanted to get a commission out of louis
the 16th was unable to
get one and finally joined the navy
of the tsarina catherine catherine the
great who finally made him an admiral he
always wanted to be an admiral and he
became an admiral in the russian navy
and he fought very bravely against the
turks in one battle uh the the uh uh off
the black sea there and the lyman uh he
uh uh rode in
a small boat into the turkish fleet in
the dead of night to recognite her took
out a piece of chalk and wrote burn this
ship paul jones on the fantail and the
next day he burned it
this is according to the
an account from a cossack crewman
uh who recorded this
he was
successful for catherine but he was
always getting into fights with his
fellow officers because he was prickly
in vain and difficult it's interesting
in his correspondence he would tell
himself that he had to be better and he
had to amend his ways and he had to be
and benjamin franklin would write him
letters saying you have to give credit
to others and you can't just be
vainglorious but human nature being what
it is he just couldn't keep it up he
would reform for a while but then he'd
go back to being
the sort of prickly vainglorious guy he
really was
uh and and be disappointed with himself
but but he's as if he couldn't help
himself he was a very lonely figure uh
he never married never had a family he
knew he would never marry uh he is
really his only love was war uh there is
a little bit of erotic dog rule that
survives uh but that's about only the
only sign of sort of human warmth if you
can call it that uh that survives from
him he does recognize in some of his
letters to his sisters uh that he had
been disappointed in human relationships
but he's essentially a lonely figure and
he goes back to he's he's disgraced in
in russia by a sex scandal he gets uh uh
his his enemies set him up i believe
he's accused of raping a 10 year old as
best i can tell from the police records
he was having consecutive consensual sex
with a minor who was a prostitute uh so
the the facts are probably not all that
great either but not as bad as he was
accused of and he was essentially run
out of russia he goes back to paris
which is in the midst of a revolution
and uh he's lonely and bored in fact the
american minister writes about jones
coming and he says that john paul jones
comes tonight has time on his hands uh
and there are many of those entries and
governor morris's diary of jones is sort
of showing up with nothing to do
and eventually at the age of 45 he dies
he's just worn out
he'd been on too many quarter decks for
too long
he'd had pneumonia his lungs were
ravaged his kidneys were shot
and he dies alone and essentially
forgotten in paris in 1792.
now he did leave a paper trail always
important for a year later fame he wrote
a lot of journals and letters and these
survive and during the course of the
19th century various romantic writers
discovered jones uh he's written about
usually as a fictional character in
james fennimore cooper melville thackery
dumas kipling all make him a character
in various ways and in various times
during the 19th century
and then very importantly he is
discovered by theodore roosevelt
and enshrined right here in annapolis
maryland
roosevelt wanted to create it needed
money for a navy needed money from
congress and the way one way to do that
was to have heroes we needed a hero and
jones is a very convenient hero so
roosevelt set over a flotilla of
battleships and they dug up jones from
his very obscure grave and they brought
him back here and they installed them in
that magnificent uh
tomb which probably many of you have
seen beneath the naval academy chapel
which was being built at about this time
looks like napoleon's tomb it's a
wonderful bozart style
jones would have loved it it was just as
glorious as it could be
and and uh and roosevelt said you know
you should to the midshipmen should
learn
uh the life and deeds of john paul jones
as an example to them uh i actually hope
the midshipmen don't try to exactly
emulate
uh jones's deeds although his courage
was a model and his care was also a
model although he was flamboyant and
proud again he was a very careful
careful sailor and he was also a
visionary he would not have been a good
fleet commander he was not admiral
nimitz he did not have the temperament
to lead large numbers of men but he was
a very brave uh combatant
uh indeed a war lover and uh his courage
should be
uh remembered it's sort of too bad he's
become a dead white male uh you know
he's he's been dropped from the history
books by and large as far as i can tell
my own kids
my own daughters said dad you know who's
john paul jones uh and i'm hoping
i said i'm hoping to bring him back
because he should be remembered he's in
that revolutionary generation he's not a
great thinker like uh adams or or
washington uh washington wasn't so much
a great thinker but a great figure he's
not on that scale but he was a he was a
powerful fighter at a time we needed
fighters and we didn't have that many of
them you look at the
military record of the revolution and
there are a lot of uh it's one big
retreat as best i can tell uh living to
fight again another day uh there aren't
too many great soldiers i guess uh
benedict arnold qualifies as a great
soldier but he was working for the other
side uh at least halfway through
so jones should be remembered and not
just as a great warrior but as an
interesting american this whole idea of
a self-invented
self-made self-created person what could
be more american than that i'm going to
give herman melville the last word here
this is from his uh
novel historical novel israel potter
intrepid unprincipled
reckless
predatory with boundless ambition
civilized and externals but savage at
heart america is or may yet be the paul
jones of nations thank you very much
[Applause]
i'm happy to take questions about our
commodore uh
yes
i'm a fan of john paul jones and i was
distressed to read the review of your
book in the wall street journal yeah the
other day it took a pretty negative view
it's true wow that's true i think he's a
little tough on him i mean this is a
warts and all biography but what it
misses some of the aspects that i've
been talking about this willingness
he wasn't in it for the money i mean in
those days
we had we had hundreds of privateers
who were in it for the doe i mean they
were these are licensed pirates
essentially they get a letter of mark
and they can go out and take british
merchantmen and they don't have to share
the doe
and the continental navy had to give
half of it back to congress and it's
clear from jones's correspondence that
he had higher ambitions than surely
making money now you could say his glory
was a big part of it but he also
uses a lot of the language he talks
about the universe the universal rights
of mankind and he appreciates the
country that he's in in fact in a letter
he writes after the war he was quite
specific about free speech and the
rights of the individual and the dignity
of the individual he understood what he
was fighting for and i think that was
missing from that from that book review
it's in my book but not in the review
that review is from a sort of cranky
scotsman i think uh who uh who took a
dim view of jones i i don't take such a
dim view of him
yes
i haven't read your book but uh i've
read a lot about general custer he
reminds me when you're talk
if you're familiar with general custer
there's the same kind of almost exact
character but but i think a lot of
military heroes now not all of them by
any means but if you think about it uh i
think of you know patton mccarthy with
his sunglasses i mean there are a lot of
vainglorious
uh military leaders and it's easy to
make fun of it but you got to get your
courage from some place and you have to
have that sort of sense grandiosity of
spirit that sense of granger that you
have been called upon to do these great
things that doesn't most of us don't
have that
it takes a rare individual i mean if you
want to elevate it
one big step up think about our
political leaders
lincoln was probably manic depressive
churchill talked about his black dog his
depressions so a lot of great leaders
have that grandiosity of spirit
that makes them believe they can do
great things they also have low lows
that that tend to come with it they deal
with their lows however and and and uh
but jones is i mean it was very
revealing to me i'm going to get a
little bit into the the weeds here but
some of you probably have read
patrick o'brien novels you know the
aubrey matron series which are these
great age of sale novels now the hero in
that
jack aubry is a bluff charming friendly
open warm character and yet
his exploits if you read master and
commander the first of that series his
exploits are directly taken from the
actual feats of thomas lord cochran
who was a real british naval officer
that whole business of taking the caca
fuego the larger spanish ship directly
lifted from cochran's
memoirs
and cochran was a dead ringer for jones
prickly vainglorious difficult paranoid
self-centered glory-seeking my point is
the real thing not jack aubry not the
fictional guy but the real guy who
really did this was just like jones he
was a jerk but he was a very effective
one
you know you can just because you're not
the most lovable person doesn't mean
that you aren't effective it takes war
lovers are not the most attractive
people often now there are many
exceptions to this there have been great
generals who are just princes but there
also been a lot that you wouldn't want
to have over for dinner
but just looking at the ocean i'm
thinking you could set out in those
ships and get from here to there you had
to be just a little bit off the edge to
do that
by our modern sensibilities of course
but you know an interesting thing about
that i read about the life of a sailor
and it's so hideous they they eat this
wretched food spoiled meat and water has
scum on it and and the you know the
biscuits have insects crawling in and
out and they're seasick all the time and
yet better than life on land for a lot
of them where they weren't eating at all
at least on a ship but you by and large
got fed they got their allotment was a
pound of meat a day because of this
heavy physical labor they they i mean
it's his life could be so base and so
crude for the lower orders at this time
that being on a ship wasn't wasn't all
that bad relatively speaking
yes back then uh mccullough makes a big
point in his john adams that adams
wanted to create an american navy
i wonder why he didn't uh glom on to
jones and make something out of that
would you like to speculate he
recognized jones's qualities i mean he
did talk about him he's the most
intriguing officer not and he met
plotting against me but he also saw some
of the his fierceness of spirit and some
of his abilities and and he paid
attention to him and he said nicer
things than that about him uh and he and
franklin did send jones out they were a
little nervous about what jones was
going to do out there uh in fact they
specifically warned him not to
get too much in the headlines uh this is
a
difficult diplomatic moment this is when
he first went out uh
the french hadn't gotten into the war
yet and it was going to be they were
still neutral they were anti-british but
they were they had not declared war on
britain so it was dangerous to be
setting out from france
and
burning a bit of england and then going
back to a french port so that made
franklin nervous but franklin and adams
did understand that jones was a fighter
uh and he was a rare thing in that and
they they appreciated that as did
jefferson
yeah about your uh subtitle when you
call him the father of the american navy
i take it you don't mean founder and you
want to no in fact
this is a this is a
let me put this carefully a publisher's
title uh
there are many claims to fathers of the
american navy including john barry uh
who was a a very good in fact actually a
better leader probably than jones was he
wasn't supposed spectacular and
importantly he did not leave a paper
trail uh we we might read him be reading
more about barry and less about jones
but jones wrote it down and barry didn't
uh barry was a little bit later he had
one good cruise on the alliance a ship
that jones also sailed in and then when
we created a real navy by building some
frigates in the 1790s i think barry got
the first commission and that's why
people call them i think that's the
reason why jones was dead by then or
dying jones was dead by then uh that's
why barry gets in some quarters as sort
of as the father of the navy other
people say that george washington is
because he created something called
washington's navy essentially fishing
boats that attacked british uh merchant
men off boston harbor and in the summer
of 1775. so there are other
other claimants to the to the title
yes did uh john paul james ever
considered himself to be an american
because i say that because he fought for
different countries that's a good
question and the answer is absolutely
yes uh he clearly did he was proud of
his country proud of his new country he
and he did understand
what was being created here this whole
idea of giving dignity to individuals
and and that that that
uh you know we scoffed the idea that all
men are created equal because in that
time there was still slavery and all men
were not created equal but that basic
idea was at least implanted
and jones grasped it and and a
an ambitious
white man of a certain social class
could aspire to be anything and that was
a new notion for a gardener's son that
was a new and liberating idea and jones
did appreciate it in fact when he met
catherine the great the great zarina the
despotis arena the first thing he did
was hand her a copy of the brand new
american constitution
so he knew where he was coming from
given his tactics um
was he viewed by the british as an emmy
combatant or had he been captured would
have been hung that's a good question an
important question because
he was viewed as a pirate they referred
to him as a pirate paul jones and this
is important because one of the reasons
why
uh
fighting if you were fighting against a
british navy and you're a french officer
you might not fight to the death if
you're an officer is that you would be
paroled if you were captured you were
going to be just traded back
uh you might you weren't going to go to
a prison hulk you weren't going to get
hung you were going to go home pretty
soon
jones had every reason to think that he
would swing
he had a reason to fight to the end and
the british newspapers pointed this out
that they said the one reason why i was
so ruthless and bloody was because he
figured he would at best end up in a
dungeon and at worst be hung now the
british never actually hung
anybody the british never actually did
hang anybody but they did throw them in
prison and pretty awful those prison
hulks were really horrible there was a
place called thing was called mill
prison in england that was not exactly
the ritz
and it was hard to get prisoner
exchanges one of jones's causes was to
create a prison he wanted to kidnap an
earl to exchange the earl for american
prisoners because it was hard to
liberate americans who had been captured
the british were treating them as
criminals and not as combatants
so uh it's an important important point
in jones is still to this day in britain
thought of as the pirate paul jones you
under one of his uh he has a little
portrait in the national gallery over
there which identifies john paul jones i
think it's it's pirate smuggler slaver
it's not founder of the american navy
yes i had the impression that he
left some legacy of training and
professionalism for the navy you haven't
mentioned that is that
there's an important somewhat
complicated point he did write letters
to robert morris his patron in the
continental congress talking about the
need for a professional navy he
understood that we needed a real navy
and he was an early visionary in that
and that's an important thing it's not
clear that he ever sent those letters to
morris uh there's there's there's some
question about which draft went where
but he at least had the idea in his head
and he wrote it down he even saw the
need for a naval academy the first
mention of training an officer class
shows up in jones's letters he wanted to
do it on ships to to create he wanted to
emulate the british navy basically and
he saw that america this great nation
was going to need a great navy uh and he
was pretty early in the game uh to do
that and deserves deserves uh credit for
it now it's a somewhat controversial
point around here because he he famously
talked about officers and a gentleman
and midshipmen today are still required
to memorize the definition of an officer
and a gentleman that jones didn't say
it comes from a bogus biography written
of john paul jones in 1900 by a
charlatan named buell
and for a hundred years midshipman at
the naval academy had been memorizing
this bogus definition of an officer and
a gentleman this year for the first time
they're changing the attribution on it
they're crediting buell
and they're then correctly quoting jones
on a facing page it only took him a
century but they finally got got their
story right
yes
richard sunk after the battle what
happened to the serapis
uh this uh i think it's pronounced
serapis i've always been curious how you
pronounce it i think it's the bona
richard and the serapis i think uh
the serapis was taken uh by jones it was
his prize of course but then they went
to uh the texel tessel which is a an
island off of amsterdam which serves as
the port it's a rhodes there and uh
in a complicated series of politics that
the dutch basically kicked jones out
uh because the the british were leaning
on the dutch were neutral and the
british were leaning on them to expel
this pirate jones and jones had to leave
the serapis behind and he sailed out in
another american ship the alliance the
serapis later was returned to the french
as a prize and then it was a stripped
bear and sold for almost nothing it was
a source of great irritation at john
paul jones that his great prize this
brand new british 2 decker was stripped
clean and sold for far less than its
actual value meaning less prize money
for jones and for his crew
in the naval history magazine interview
you commented on going to sea in a ship
that was a replica of chef jones served
on could you talk about that the
providence is a 70-foot sloop there's a
replica of it it's not a precise replica
because it's fiberglass and not wood
which is to two tall ship advocates a
big no-no
but it sure looks like one to me and the
rigging and all was all the same and it
sails out of providence it's maintained
by the providence of maritime heritage
foundation a very nice group of people
and i
uh they i went out and sailed through
block island sound at night where he had
fought his first naval battle uh aboard
the alfred against the glasgow uh so i
got a feel for on the ship that he was
actually he was on a different ship that
night but he later commanded the
providence
uh in the same orders uh and uh was fun
but it was also you got to feel what
really struck me
this ship is only 70 feet long in
jones's day they had 70 men on a 70-foot
ship can you imagine what that was like
in addition to ducks geese chicken
pens
i mean it it all stuffed in together
jones had the captain's cabin was the
only thing approaching civility this is
not unusual in the british navy by rule
men were given 14 inches to sling their
hammocks
now it actually worked out to 28 because
it would be one watch off one watch on
but they were really they would cram
hundreds of men into these into these
ships because they require tremendous
manpower i mean you didn't have geared
winches here you had you know you had a
capstan but uh and but but basically it
was just raw manpower uh pulling on all
those ropes and swinging around all
those heavy guns
uh and it took a lot of men and they
were crammed in all there together and
really wretched
cold miserable jones took this little
providence up off nova scotia uh to raid
british fisheries up there and uh gave a
famous pep talk to his little fleet
which included the providence and a
couple of other ships about how
important it was to stay up there to
liberate the americans who were
imprisoned in the coal mines there and
he gave this great speech and the crew
of the providence immediately turned
around and sailed to himself
jones had trouble hanging on to his
cruise
uh
uh but you know it was these are new
england farm boys who are used to
democracy a lot of them they were used
to town meetings they wanted to vote on
whether you should go into battle it
wasn't the british navy in fact
interestingly jones who believed in the
lash and and flogging people and did it
various occasions do it never flogged
anybody on the right ranger his if you
look at the logs no record of flogging i
believe that's because he knew he
couldn't get away with it if he did it
once he was going to wind up in the
drink
they were because they wouldn't stand
for it his crew which is these uh
new hampshire farm boys
weren't going to stand for it some of
them were former pirates on pirate ships
in that area you did vote it was it was
it was a the captain was the the first
among equals but you would vote to go
into battle and that's essentially what
they were doing on the ranger only
uh the first mate would lead a vote and
it wasn't what jones the first mate
would vote to leave to go away and jones
would say no no we're going to fight
and it took a certain amount of
willpower just to force the force the
fight
which fortunately jones had
yes
said his opponent in the battle got
knighted later on but what was the
reaction to losing uh from the british
standpoint uh it infuriated them but the
the worst thing would be to lose to a
frenchman or a spaniard that was at
least jones was a countryman and they
made a point of saying well at least
he's like he's one of us sort of i mean
he's a scotsman
but he's pretty much he speaks our
language so that was that made it better
it was just inexcusable to lose to the
french or the spanish but it was okay if
one of your own uh and they made a lot
of excuses about how he was going to
hang that's why he fought to the end
also it's also true that pearson got his
knighthood partly because while he was
fighting with jones the merchant fleet
he was escorting got away uh it was
people carrying a naval storage in naval
stores from
scandinavia to uh to london and they
escaped so the uh uh the russia company
as it was called which was bringing over
these stores gave a lot of silver plate
to captain pearson for having saved as
save their save their fleet
uh
yes
that's okay
you remarked that the nation needed a
hero
and yet you seem to say that he didn't
get much
adulation
are there contemporary press reports and
recognition of his hero status in the
united states not much there's a little
bit
when he comes back to philadelphia in
1781 he gets a little glory he has a
celebration on his ship in the school
call and there's a
he gets a few pets on the back and
congress gives him a gold medal
so it's he gets a ride but it's not as
much of a ride as he wanted
and probably not as much as he deserved
communications weren't all that great
between uh great britain and and between
france and the united states in fact i
think in the first year all of benjamin
franklin's correspondence was
intercepted
partly because benjamin franklin's
secretary was a british spy
joan one of jones's few friends
bancroft edward bancroft was a british
spy every every this is benjamin
franklin secretary every tuesday night
he was going out into the tweeleries and
putting secrets in a bottle which were
picked up by british agents and taken to
the and and we found my researcher found
in the records of the british admiralty
uh information from bancroft selling out
jones saying you know he was going to
his ship was going to go here on next
date or why date and uh now it didn't
joan survived it but but there was a spy
in their midst and that helps explain
why franklin was having trouble getting
his messages uh across the sea or may
explain it it's not clear exactly what
happened there but it was there wasn't
great communication this is it took took
at best six weeks to cross the ocean and
and uh the word didn't always get home
yeah i remember reading a few years ago
about a
the difficulty they had when they wanted
to move jones remains back to the u.s
how
how hard it was to find his body
yeah
do you think we have the jones bones in
an atmosphere well i know we do because
uh he the french kindly pickle them in
alcohol and i've seen a photograph of of
the corpse it's a little grisly but it
looks exactly like the hudan sculpture
uh there is a famous sculpture of jones
which is an exact likeness of him and
the comparison between
the skull was still flesh on it a little
grizzly but uh it was
produced from the it was sealed and lead
it was it was alcohol sealed and lead
and when they took them out and they had
a team of doctors look at them it was
the dimensions the the face mask
everything about it was clearly uh john
paul jones i think there's no credit
question about that they got the right
guy in that
tomb over there
you mentioned farm boys how prominent
were former british citizens
among those sailors and for example were
the officers of the american navy
characteristically perhaps former
british sailors uh it was a mixed bag on
the ranger uh it really was mostly farm
boys and and from
new hampshire who or merchant men or
ship builders should build their sons uh
were from around nashua new hampshire
and and also the northern massachusetts
on the bonery chart it was a very
eclectic international crew i mean there
were hindus portuguese a lot of french a
company of irish marines
fighting for france
it was the league of all nations in fact
they had real communication problems
because nobody spoke anybody else's
language
this is a bigger problem for jones when
he went to russia and really didn't
speak the language
so it was no wonder he had trouble
keeping people together now were there
any brits amongst them
not that i can recall i mean they're
mostly
they're mostly
uh
new england
uh
merchant sailors or slavers uh some of
them have been sailed and slayed who
don't have combat experience that's one
of the problems these are not
professional officer class
and that's one reason why they're in
discipline jones got lucky dale his
first lieutenant on the bonham richard
was a good fighter
but simpson his first lieutenant on the
ranger was a disaster kept mutinying
against them
[Music]
so it was at best a mixed bag but i
don't remember any former royal navy
officers anywhere in any of those crew
i'm thinking about it but i don't
remember any in any of the amongst his
officers
yes
yes one last question the uh
the one man you cited earlier that he'd
killed is he the only one
of record
uh
well that's a good question that we know
uh did jones kill anybody else let me
think about this
right with his own hands you mean uh
well uh you know i think probably he was
the only one he
he i'm trying to think of his battles uh
when he was on the bonum richard he was
mostly
uh uh he almost killed his own gunners
mate when he threw a pistol at his head
that's but he didn't kill him uh he
manned a cannon that was uh probably
killed some men
uh when he was fighting the turks
he almost surely killed some men because
they were aborted once by turks who are
working for the capitan pasha this is a
great character copy down pascha was the
turkish leader had a pet pet tiger or
pet lion
a vicious guy who routinely burned and
hung his men i mean a pretty tough
customer and uh uh
joan the battles against the turks were
kind of hair-raising because the turks
would come down on you screaming cymbals
clashing
you know yelling death to the infidel
and jones had some close quarter fights
in those battles in which i assume he
killed a man but as i think of it i
don't remember any descriptions of him
doing that
i guess that's it
any more
dead white males you plan to write about
uh well i'm thinking about it i'm
working on it
thank you very much
i'm gonna sign some books now for
anybody
next week on history bookshelf david
mccullough talks about his book john
adams
mr mccullough describes